everyone
the apparent Oscar winner Jamie Lee
Curtis is entering the room
[Applause]
stop now thank you
all right thank you so much everyone
okay we're going to start with number
205 and then next after that we'll move
to 150. what are they bidding on
what do they win
they win me
good evening Jamie over here over here
in the middle of the room my
Straight Ahead Jamie straight ahead I
have big hoop earrings on
back one five okay now you're waving I'm
sorry now I see you sorry you're 205 in
the back yes 205. hello hello hi
congratulations on this so much
congratulations I'm Tanisha Laverne
Grant with black in america.com there
are 65 women this year nominated for
Academy Awards across various
disciplines how does it feel for you to
be amongst that number
surreal
and proud and
obviously I would like to see a lot more
women be nominated so that there's
gender parity in all the areas and all
the branches and I think we're getting
there we're not anywhere near there
and of course the inclusivity then
that involves the bigger question which
is do you how do you include everyone
when there are binary choices which is
very difficult and is the mother of a
trans daughter I completely understand
that and yet to degender the category
also I'm concerned will diminish the
opportunities for more women which is
something I also have been working hard
to try to promote so it's a complicated
question but I think the most important
thing is inclusivity and more women I
mean basically just [__] more women
anywhere anytime all at once
all right and next we have number 154
before I feel like you just won the like
bad cruiset set La Cruze no it's a
lovely in Orange
Angela Bishop hello Angela Australia
it's great to see you my hairdresser
Sean James is from Australia yes I love
him oh you look wonderful thank you
congratulations thank you so much well
reserved award
you are everyone's favorite nepo baby as
you said do you think your mum and dad
are looking down on you tonight and
smiling well let me just be honest I
don't I don't believe in a world where
there are a bunch of people up there
looking down on us
um I I
think we are them
in our actions and in our deeds and in
our ideas and then we build our own and
then we give them to our children and
that's how the world goes on so I am a
product of them and I am a proud product
of them and I know that they would be
incredibly proud of me of course thank
you
um next up we are taking a question from
our virtual press room before moving to
321 so virtualbox by the way the virtual
people don't get [__] they don't get the
food they don't get water
they're at home their kids are screaming
their husbands cheating on them
they're so bummed out they want to be
here with you people so bad
sorry we have aniko from Hungary well
Hungary of course the country of my
family
Tony Curtis that came from Hungary
Jamie hi and I have good news for you I
have food oh excellent good
good
oh you're actually I thought it was just
sort of like a tweet I didn't realize
you they were people on guys
don't now don't cancel me
please do not cancel me because I
assumed that your husband is cheating on
you
I literally thought when they said
digital that it was like uh a virtual
that I thought it was like a tweet
question
seriously
do not ruin this moment for me
I cannot handle it if you cancel me now
cancel me tomorrow
just not tonight give me a break I'm so
sorry if I was insulting I please tell
me something from Hungary
yes yes yes and I don't have a husband
thank you okay
um so did you have a question yes I do
I'm gonna answer it
hey uh first of all can we consider this
at least a semi-hungarian Oscar
oh yeah the lower half
definitely in the lower half how much
Hungarian how much Hungarian I can't
really show you on National Television
but how much am I well that's very
personal
um I can I can sing that little song
katitsa
I Won't sing to you people because
Stephanie Shu just sang and she can sing
I can't so anyway I love my Hungarian
heritage
yes
the room got really quiet so much that
was the last question oh my goodness me
I'm so sorry so now you people are gonna
hate it um get back into this because I
cracked wise I'm so sorry
but I'm taking this really seriously and
this is the thrill of my life
and please don't cancel me
please
thank you